الملحن والمطرب المصري عمرو مصطفى اثار
الجدل بعد نشر لمق نشره لمقطع فيديو
لاغنيته الجديده من وهي من الحانه للسيده
ام كلثوم صممت باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي
نهدا كل شيء ممكن الان الاغنيه من المقرر
ان تنشر كامل قريبا بحسن مصطفى لكنها
اغضبت احد المنتجين الذي حذر من استخدام
التقنيه لاستحضار صوت كوكب الشرق وهدد
ايضا باللجوء للقضاء عمرو بررر من خلال
حديثه للعربيه للعربيه نت قال ان الصوت
المستخدم ليس صوت ام كلثوم الحقيقي وهل
كلمات ليست مملوكه لاي منتج ولا الالحان
وبالتالي لم يتم انتهاك اي حقوق ادبيه ليش
زعلانين على كل حال احنا راح نستمع للمقطع
الذي نشره عمرو مصطفى والذي نؤكد انه ام
كلثوم اكيد انتم عارفين لم تغنيه ابدا هذا
ذكاء اصطناعي
[موسيقى]
جايه
حاطط
واو كانه طبيعي كانه حقيقي فعلا
انا انا صدمت
كانه بالفعل صوت ام كلثوم حتى بالتسجيل
بالجوده القديمه كانه بروفا في شقتها او
في بيتها لتسجيل هذه الاغنيه في الاستديو
عاده ما هي تقوم مع مع طاقم الموسيقي مع
بتدريبات قبل الاغنيه
سمعت مره اسطوانه كانت عباره عن
بروفا وهي النسخه وحيده موجوده غير كلمه
بعض الكلمات احمد رامي على ما اذكر لكن
الذكاء الاص
طناعي
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات